musique toujours mais cette fois dans la
france profonde comme l'ont dit et plus
précisément dans le gers à marcillac qui
organise depuis plusieurs années
maintenant un festival de jazz très
réputé une petite ville qui décidément
aime la musique puisque les enfants de
6e ont la possibilité de suivre des
cours de jazz dans le cadre scolaire
bien sûr l'occasion de faire une
démonstration de leurs juvénile talent
reportage en yves perrin jacques gâche
le big band le plus jeune de france
ils ont tous 11 ans ils sont élèves de
6e au collège de marciac une sixième un
peu particulière une sixième case toute
l'année ils travaillent assidûment la
musique après les cours un homme ce
régime
ça donne quelques idées on n'avait pas
prévu
oh
ça confère aussi quelques privilèges
comme celui de rencontrer les grands
noms du jazz à la fiche du festival de
marciac
là c'est une leçon animé par oscar
peterson le pianiste canadien qui aiment
venir dans la région
pendant une heure il a refait l'histoire
du jazz en précisant espiègle que le
jazz ça ne s'apprend pas en quelques
mois message reçu
et quand elle explique à est un peu plus
professional professionnels il en rêve
tous après seulement un an de musique et
même si cette initiation au jazz unique
en france n'est surtout pas fait pour ça
il se verrait bien un jour jouer sur la
grande scène de marciac
en solo le dernier journal